the Donald Trump presidency has set a
few records mostly bad ones right
quickest President to majority
disapproval over fifty percent
disapproval quickly destroying the
opinion of the United States around the
world as I told you last week this is
the sort of day's news and in a sense
it's not majorly important to a lot of
our lives as Trump at 36 38 or 41
percent approval rating but it is
becoming a very interesting situation
for the history of this presidency with
Donald Trump's approval ratings staying
low and still no major accomplishment to
speak of and none on the horizon except
maybe taking health care away from tens
of millions of people we have a
continued stagnant approval rating and
growing support for the impeachment of
the President of the United States and
the question we are now sort of faced
with is how long can a president weather
this storm and by storm I mean not an
acute hurricane to use an analogy but
rather the constant pounding of heavy
rain day after day according to Gallup
Donald Trump's approval rating is still
very very low most recently at 37%
basically within the margin of error
equaling his presidency low this you
probably know but a stunning number to
compare it to is that a 47% 47% of
voters according to a recent PPP poll
support the impeachment of Donald Trump
the portion of the public that supports
impeaching the president exceeds the
approval rating of the president by 10
percentage points this is not normal and
what happens next is sort of the key
question here is this a good sign Pat
that when you lie and insult others and
accomplish nothing there are
consequences or is it a bad sign that
despite people feeling this way not a
damn thing will happen well 47% does
sound very high but there's also it
always seems that there's a significant
portion of the population who supports
impeaching the incumbent president no
matter what Bill Clinton it was over the
Lewinsky scandal with George Bush it was
over war crimes Obama maybe he was born
in Kenya
thing we don't war about that one war
attention but you know we have
significant reasons to do so with him if
he potentially colluded with the foreign
government to get him elected or
increasingly more important justice
correct and therein lies the problem
which is who cares about the issues
Pat's talking about well who brought
Trump to power in the first place
Donald Trump came to power by coalescing
retrograde nationalism nativism and
xenophobia in an electorate that we've
learned is basically unconcerned with
facts and mostly interested in making
liberals angry for them having elected
Donald Trump what do you need in order
to realize how ludicrous the status quo
is under the current president well you
need an open mind and you need an
openness to facts what do we have we
have a continued push from the right
towards anti intellectualism and
arguably worse is the pseudo
intellectual ISM that we're seeing I
want to explain that anti
intellectualism is pretty
straightforward right hey college is
liberal indoctrination just get the hell
out of there nuanced policy perspectives
on things like taxation are liberal
nonsense so-called experts are just
liberal hacks bla bla bla bla right anti
intellectualism is pretty straight
forward the pseudo intellectual ism is
arguably more dangerous and much more
difficult to fight this includes for
example people who read the books of
people like Mark Levin and Laura
Ingraham and they think hey I'm an
informed thinking person I read books
whatever that is a major major problem
because you've got people there pat who
believe that they are informed they're
not saying hey information and facts or
liberal nonsense they're saying no I
value information in fact like those
presented by intellectuals among the
right Mark Levin and Laura Ingraham and
that's arguably more dangerous because
those folks are probably even more
steeped and ingrained in their
pre-existing beliefs you know it's like
how some people think that anything that
you read on the internet or watch on the
Internet is just inherently untrue
because of the method of where you got
it from with books it's I mean it's the
same thing it depends on what the
for content and is what the sourcing is
and the more I think about this and I
think about how Trump came to power the
more I'm convinced that forget about how
Trump's presidency ends right whether
it's in six months or at the end of his
current term or at the end of a second
term right Donald Trump's presidency is
far more likely to lead to Trump 2.0
another Trump type politician then to a
total rejection of the ideology that put
Trump in power to begin with because the
people that elected him doesn't matter
what he does they see it as a victory
they see Donald Trump's presidency as a
success already despite the fact that
he's done very close to nothing other
than bad things and if anything they
will be emboldened and we are more quite
more likely to get Trump 2.0 than a
rejection of trumpism unless
progressives actually activate and by
the way get Democrats Inc or corporate
Democrats as I call it out of power send
me your thoughts on this I know I threw
a lot at you but this is this is big
stuff that's happening I'm on Twitter at
the Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show